that coworker who's perfectly alert on 6
hours while you're dragging after 8.
There's a scientific reason the Japanese
sleep just 6.5 hours but live longer
with more energy than Americans sleeping
7.5. They're secret. They don't count
hours, they count cycles. Your brain
runs 90minute sleep cycles.
Wake at 6 or 7.5 hours, you're golden.
But 8 hours, you're literally
interrupting your brain midcycle.
It's like leaving a movie during the
climax. The Japanese treat bedrooms at
60 to 64° F, 5° cooler than yours. Your
body needs to drop temperature for deep
sleep. Plus, they master inimury
strategic napping. NASA approved
26-minute naps boost performance 34%.
Set your alarm for 6, 7.5, or 9 hours.
Never 7 or 8. Tonight you begin Japanese
sleep mastery. Tomorrow you wake up
fresh.